hey guys Anna welcome back to the Leia
Heil pen show joining me on the show
today we have the president of The
Hourglass Collective he's the executive
producer of the brand new TV show which
I'm actually a judge on called the next
crypto Gem and he's formerly an
investment banker and has broken over
100 million dollars in mergers and
Acquisitions so I guess he's the kind of
guy you definitely want on your team so
join me on the show today we have jet
Tang jet welcome how are you hey Leah
it's great to be here it's so good to
have you we haven't seen each other
since I think since when we did that
neft party thing that's right that's
right back in April that was pretty fun
the 20s theme party right yeah yeah
absolutely so we have the next crypto
gem TV show coming out it's all very
exciting
um I want to get into all of that um so
let's talk about how we actually met
first I think
um we met in person for the first time
in LA when we first filmed the TV show
but we met for the first time through
the producers of the TV show and through
the the production company and and
everything like that through uh I think
it was Zoom or something did a little
video conference and a funny story is
that when we were creating the show we
wanted to show uh crypto in a good light
because you know so much of the
mainstream media they're just basically
just [__] on crypto whenever they
can and we wanted to do something that
shows the other side and the people and
personalities involved and you were
actually one of the first people that I
thought of that way to be a judge on the
show and it actually we were so happy
that it worked out and we met your
brother Gideon he's so freaking cool and
we just we're thrilled that it all came
to fruition it's all happening right now
that's so funny because so the way that
we actually got connected was um the
production company who produced the show
they emailed me um I think it was back
in November last year I remember me and
getting out for a coffee or something
one evening and we got an email through
from from Michael actually and um we
checked out the we checked out the
production company and I was really
surprised that they were interested in
me because you know they seemed very
like rainbow flags and like diversity
and you know very woke to put it
politely and you know my content is just
not it's just not that right and I was
said to Gideon I was like do you think
they researched me or like do you think
like do you think they just saw that I
was like a crypto person and I'm a woman
will take her he's like do you think
they like saw the stuff that is a really
really good observation um well bespoke
TV is uh partially owned by a um Jeff
Mahoney who's who's funding the whole
project so he as you met Jeff he's the
billionaire that I work with he's also
the chairman of The Hourglass Collective
and so I think everyone in Hollywood is
kind of is kind of woke but the the key
executive producers him and myself uh we
wanted diversity of opinion you know I
mean one of the things that I can't
stand is that when people think
diversity is just all these people of
different shades of skin color and
ethnicity and they're all saying the
exact same thing right we didn't want
that we wanted totally different types
of people so we wanted someone like you
who has really interesting views and who
is a bit of a Bitcoin Maxi on on the
show we wanted someone like George
someone like Brian who all comes from a
a different uh different Arena and
that's what makes it interesting it's
like a salad you have to all these
different flavors you know and so I
think it came out really well because
you guys had a lot of chemistry in
different ways and a lot of fun clashes
and I think that that's what
entertainment's all about yeah no I
agree you know diversity of opinion
rather than of skin color makes a lot
more
it's practically logistically and
everything else um but no it was really
I really liked when we met because I did
feel slightly out of place before we had
met because I was like I feel like a
fraud at one minute do these people know
who I am like like because I don't know
I think even on a phone call somebody
had said to me like you know we really
want to you know you know get more women
into this and I'm like right
in the writer's room there was kind of
this moment where Michael told the whole
crew and the people in the in the
writer's room now I just want to let you
guys know there's a little bit of a
controversial person on her show her
name is her name is Leah Halpern and she
says things like this this this this
is like what what did he show them uh I
don't remember exactly was it like
there's only two genders
wait or something
well
this was really overweight I don't
remember exactly what it was no I think
you're right it was about fat people
yeah it's unhealthy yeah and so yeah he
he he he did that and he said that if
anyone wants to leave the production
because of it then you can do so now
here's your warning and then everyone's
just kind of like no one left the
production so everything came out okay
and um I I kept on telling everyone look
look Leia is a really really cool person
I've known her really well
you're allowed to have different
opinions and we can't get into this
thing in this world where everyone can
only think in one particular way I mean
if you look at any of the dystopian
Sci-Fi movies that's that's how
everything falls apart you know yeah and
so
um I think it was just but you know what
I think over time people started to like
you and why wouldn't you I'm very nice
yeah so even the people that thought
they were gonna hate you when they met
you on set it kind of It kind of changed
things they hated that they loved me
yeah yeah exactly so you grew on the on
the production cast that was good over
time that's good yeah I know it was an
interesting experience and you know
obviously once we got down there
um yeah it was a lot of fun I felt um I
was quite exhausted actually
um because we flew in from Miami and um
you know we filmed straight away and
there were really long hours I can't
remember I think we I think we've had to
be there at like seven maybe or yeah I
can't remember and we were done by seven
in the evening sometimes 7 30 so it was
like a really long 12 hour our day of
filming and there was a lot of waiting
around as well which also exhausted you
um but it no it was it was great and um
you know obviously we did a lot of
dinners and stuff while we were out in
La that was nice yeah yeah and I I am
sorry about the the first day of craft
service no it's not up to your standard
so for you guys who don't know like the
first generally the craft service was
pretty good but the first day they were
in a rush and it wasn't very good and
then you had a stomach geek I got kind
of sick yeah I felt kind of bad about
that no it's okay hopefully we made it
up when we took you and Gideon to
Morton's Steakhouse that was much much
better right yeah yeah I know it was
delicious it was delicious but no what
really surprised me um when it came to
filming was just how much waiting around
there was I really couldn't believe it
um you know we could be we were told to
be on set for like 7 A.M and sometimes
you wouldn't even start filming until
like 11 you know to be honest with you
though this is just how Productions are
when you have like so many people on set
so many crew and you have like seven RED
cameras it just takes a lot of time to
say set up before they're they're
rolling and I back in the day I used to
be an actor and I was even did some
really high budget films where I had
little roles in it and it's even slower
sometimes you could spend the whole day
to only get like a couple minutes so um
unfortunately that is just kind of goes
with with the territory yeah um but you
handled it really well and when the time
was right and it was action you always
you absolutely killed it and so I think
that people are going to be really
entertained excited and enthralled by uh
by the show yeah you know what I really
liked about the show as well was um so
firstly the the name of the show the
next crypto Jeb I think is somewhat
misleading in a way because people think
that like we're like promoting all these
[__] coin projects and and all of that
and it's actually not really the case
because a massive part of the show was
simply just like crypto education and
teaching people
um very simple things like what is a
blockchain what is decentralization you
know what are the problems with the
traditional Financial system and that's
actually why one of my favorite episodes
of the show was when we had all these
normies coming oh yeah pointers yeah the
no coin is oh my God that was such a
crazy experience we were teaching them
about crypto but actually the funniest
part was the fact um was the casting
because you really had like they looked
so Normie like they just looked like you
had all these like weird quirky random I
mean I think it was a fair challenge
because look if you're these projects
are saying that they're vying to be the
next crypto gem that means that their
leaders should be at least able to
explain the very very basics of crypto
and blockchain right because I think a
great project their leaders should be a
great advocate for all of crypto not
just their own yeah and so I thought it
was a fair Challenge and uh some of them
did better than others but they were all
scrambling a little bit they all I think
they didn't see they didn't quite see it
coming yeah you know the challenges on
the show were actually really difficult
um and I felt sorry for some of them so
what I thought was really interesting
was just how difficult some of the
challenges were so I'm not gonna name
um project names just in case I give
anything away I don't know you know when
everything's been released or whatever
but there was one person and one
contestant and he was just so stressed
the poor guy he was such as I went up to
him like can I help you with anything
you know and we as judges right we had
to uh really lay in on them and we had
to distract them that was one of the
tasks it was you know to interrupt them
while they try and like prepare a speech
or whatever it is and I just felt so bad
guys I actually know exactly what you're
talking about yeah and I felt bad too
yeah and um I you know part of it was I
think that the challenge was difficult
but I think that also just the pressure
right you're on TV on TV show you know
this is going to be seen by so many
people and uh you know at the end I'm
glad that at least like he delivered
something yeah and so it it ended up
okay yeah it was a little bit worried
that he might have a meltdown I know I
saw that coming now yeah he did all
right in the end um but I'm actually
curious like how did you
um get all the projects together and
shortlist them to then obviously give
them to ask the judges because there was
one project
um and I just didn't understand why they
even had a position or why they got as
far as they did in in the in the
competition because and I people will
see this when they watch the show but I
kept going on about the fact that it
lacked any utility this one particular
project I'm like no you just lack
utility I don't get what you're doing
here you know what so I think the reason
why is kind of the same reason why we
had diversity in in judges is that we
wanted to show different sides of crypto
and I think that the the reality is that
Meme tokens and and tokens without any
utility are actually a big part of
crypto
um so I think you know next season we're
probably gonna have like 10 times as
many applicants and it will be a long
long sifting process process we're gonna
go bigger and better in every way we'll
have a lot of fun and uh but in this in
this season I think that it wasn't just
the projects it was also how the project
leaders came off on film right they're
the Charisma the entertainment value you
so it's kind of like a mix of all of
those things that I think at the end of
the day the the you know the four teams
that made it to the final La taping it
was it was pretty good entertainment
pretty pretty good choice you know yeah
you make a really good point actually
because that particular project that I'm
thinking of they definitely had like a
funny Dynamic right and they added a lot
of value for entertainment purposes and
also if they weren't there then you
wouldn't be able to grill them on how
comfortable is in utility right so so it
created that conflict conflict is what
all entertainment comes from generally
yeah yeah one thing which I am worried
about
um was
across at certain times I'll explain so
Joe George once told me that when I did
a piece of camera I came across as like
quite like arrogant and condescending
and I'll explain what happened so we
were talking about the FDIC that's what
they're called right and in America and
how they ensure you up to 250 000 and so
we did this um we did this like piece of
camera and I was sort of saying how um
you know
they in the no coin episode sorry
um one of the one of the normies said I
don't understand why we need blockchain
you know the FDIC will secure you up to
250 000. so my re when I when we did the
Looking Back episode my reaction to that
was it's only 250 000 like they make you
they make you the system and the bankers
right and and the government like they
make you think 250 000 is a lot of money
right right and I understand that it is
I'm not saying that it's not I'm just
saying you shouldn't look at it as like
oh don't worry you're in short up to 250
000 don't don't try and make more money
than 250 000 like we got you after you
don't need more than 250 000 it is kind
of that I think yeah I spoke about that
right right and I just don't think I'm
articulating myself very well and what
I'm saying and I think it might have
come across as like a little bit
arrogant and a little bit out of touch
because of course 250k is a lot of money
but the mind the idea that they only
assure you up to that right kind of
keeps you down right right I mean for
people have they're certainly for some
people that's a lot and they'll never
get anywhere near that so they feel like
they're protected but there are tons of
people and tons of the wealth is way
above that so how about that right so I
absolutely get your point but I didn't
think that that was actually personally
I didn't think that was condescending at
all as opposed to your segment where
you're kind of rip defining what a no
coiner is that was a little bit
condescending but also hilarious uh
maybe we could show that clip
a nocoiner is somebody that doesn't own
any cryptocurrency there are nine to
Fiverr
did I realize the entire system is a
scam and it's designed to keep you poor
they're stuck inside the Matrix forever
a slave to the system and they're still
trading time for dollars
how's my hair
to give like some context to that no
coiner thing so Justin the director he
told me to give a little bit of sass he
he wanted a lot I kind of like you know
but to be the funny the funny thing is
actually I meant everything that I said
like that is a No Quarter it is a normie
who's trading time for dollars he does
the nine to five I mean I wrote the
script but I don't think like um like
when you meet me I come across as like
quite sweet but like sure these are
genuinely my opinions and they can
genuinely be offensive I think that I
think that's okay that's okay I think
that people just need to have uh an open
mind and have thicker skin and just let
people have different opinions and hear
them out and still uh be be interacting
and cool with them in general so yeah
what were the funniest moments for you
on the show because I remember you just
like sitting in like the director's area
just like giggling in the back like I
just I just have that in my head just
like I can't believe that just happened
did I enjoyed your clashes with George
oh that was fun yeah I think there was
something about it where it was kind of
like a dynamic of like an uncle and a
niece or something where it's almost
like you had like this like thing where
like you knew each other you liked each
other but you just went at each other's
throats kind of and um so I think that
that was one of the my favorite overall
Dynamics well no I mean that that's it
that's a good point because I think like
Brian was like super chill I felt like
Brian was like always on the fence about
The Peacemaker yeah the Diplomatic and
uh kind of level-headed one whereas you
guys were well yeah because like I said
like the the Justin the director like he
wanted that like you know entertainment
excitement and like I don't know it just
came naturally with George because like
George would come out of nowhere and be
like this is my opinion you know and
then so I'd be like well you're wrong
[__] you know why not and so I don't
know I felt like there was a natural
kind of like banter that I could like
exploit there and we actually didn't
know each other beforehand like
obviously I I'd heard of crypto RS and I
know he knew me and I knew Brian as well
but we'd never actually connected or had
spoken because like you mentioned I'm
more in like the Bitcoin World well at
the time I was wearing the big tree
World
um and you know like George is clearly
very much in the old coin space right
and the [__] Queen space
and so I I never really actually uh had
spoken with him before
um but yeah that it did yes it did
surprise me how quickly that kind of
like banter had uh had transpired I also
remember when one of the projects said
you said your name wrong and then I was
with I was hanging out with your brother
Gideon and we were like oh they're gonna
lose points
you know that's like that's like one of
the biggest things for me like I don't
know if it's um I don't want to call it
an ego thing I feel like it's not an ego
thing so I don't maybe I have an ego but
it's not that big it's probably average
you know for average it's pretty
standard but Southie Davis have a
healthy healthy level of an ego
um my problem with people spelling and
saying my name wrong is is like if if
you can't spell my name right then like
you lack
um what's the word begins you lack a
level of conscientiousness and it's like
I don't respect that like I only want to
work with people or be friends with
people who are conscientious they pay
attention and then I also find it
slightly disrespectful especially
because like I am a judge on the show
right and like due diligence your job is
to impress me right right and like if
you can't even figure out how to spell
my say or spell my name correctly it
means you you lack a level of of
something and now if you lack it in this
area you're probably gonna lack it in
all the other areas including your
project like are you are you paying
attention to the price of your coin you
paying attention to the different things
that's going on with all their different
intricacies within your Project's
ecosystem right right probably not so
now you don't have my vote because you
can't get my name right people can't get
a project right like it's like a leading
indicator right overall competence and
dude and yeah
if you plug out my name right how are
you going to get your project right like
this is the easiest part of it you know
so yeah but I wasn't a fan of that
project you were you no I wasn't not
just because you didn't get my name
right because I felt that they were
really um on the show just to promote um
their project rather than like uh do
their best to to
um winning the challenges you know well
I think it worked out in some cases like
remember there were cases that were
specific to promoting the project so in
that cases they were doing what they're
meant to do but I remember there was one
specific challenge with the no coiners
where the task wasn't about that and you
felt that they were overly just using
that as an opportunity to promote
themselves yeah yeah yeah I think that
you know this is kind of a proof of
concept for season one it's not perfect
if you like I was recently watching the
show about the American Gladiators TV
show on Netflix and it talks about how
in season one they did all these things
some of them worked and then they kept
those and then some things like didn't
work right and then they had to throw
them out and kind of revamp it so I
think that the good news is that for for
season two we're gonna be able to take
all this feedback we're gonna be able to
look at you know the a lot of the stuff
that did work and then make some
improvements and it'll be uh a lot more
a lot more to work with you know
especially by then it's a known entity
because one thing that we struggled with
is that when we said we're going to do a
mainstream crypto TV show a lot of
people didn't even believe us right I
mean some people still don't believe us
with like you know right now as we're
filming this it's like a few days away
and they still think is it even really
going to come out I I mean I think at
this point most people do but there was
a certain level of skepticism now that
they'll see the production quality they
say that we you know have a really good
product
uh I mean I've had people come through
that have said that I have 20 projects
refer have big projects come directly
small projects everything so next time
around we'll have a lot more to work
with Okay yeah no that's gonna be really
interesting I'm excited I think it's
it's gonna be a whole nother level
um but something people keep asking me
is about the distribution and I
understand that there's a wide
distribution so yeah how did you decide
with the distribution and how and how is
it going to look like yeah absolutely
well bespoke TV is one our producer and
they also do some of their own
distribution so they um bespoke TV is
available on you know this distro tv
they're on they brokered a deal with
DirecTV to be on prime time and we also
work with Insight TV which is their own
channel that has very very broad
distribution and they're on close to I
think 178 platforms 56 countries so
they're all over the place uh one of the
things that is a little bit tricky is
that when you deal with so so much broad
distribution you don't get as much
attention from every single distributor
so what we might look at next time is
choose one really big streamer do an
exclusive deal and just work with them
on the whole run up and and everything
it'll be a little bit easier but as of
now we're a few days from the premiere
and it'll be kind of like an audition is
first we know we're going to be on a ton
of platforms and see which ones give us
the best placement the ones that give us
the hero page placement on top and you
know promote the show the best those are
the ones that we're gonna push to and
look at for next time okay so it's
really interesting so you chose a wider
distribution so it's going to be in a
lot of places can you confirm at least
like three for us yeah absolutely uh
DirecTV definitely
um distro TV is a is an app that's
available almost everywhere and will be
in every country including all of all of
Asia as well
um Samsung TV Vizio LG Pluto I know that
will be on on all of those if you go to
our hourglass Twitter and we'll always
show the latest right there okay yeah
okay well exciting um let's talk a
little bit about hourglass
um like what what is hourglass why did
you decide to create this TV show right
absolutely well The Hourglass Collective
we're a group it's a it's actually a
group that's built around a ownership
renowned token that's 100 circulating
and it was pretty much just a just a
regular crypto Community there was
nothing there in the beginning it was it
was mostly just almost like a meme coin
but the thing that changed everything
was I was able to get Jeff Mahoney
involved to be our chairman and uh he is
a as you know you met Jeff he's a very
very wealthy and successful individual
he's a billionaire he's the um founder
of save daily which is a fintech giant
that has 7 000 institutional clients
including IBM MetLife
um Intel pretty much everyone and he
also owns many many other companies
including he has ownership in bespoke TV
and several mobile apps neft vodka
obviously is a big one I think a lot of
people that follow us know about and so
I went to Jeff and I said hey be part of
this hourglass Collective and let's try
to do something special and then um so
when hourglass formed I think it was
around August of last year
um and I came to him I was like hey this
is a way to dip your toes into the space
again and someone like you you'd be
probably one of the most successful
people outside the web 3 space to come
in and uh they like the idea right away
so I was like okay what can we do
there's so many things that we can do
because he has all these apps with tons
of users we can integrate our token into
he has a very successful dating app a
money transfer app the TV production
company the Vodka they throw epic events
all over the world where they have like
celebrities socialites Tech CEOs
billionaires them you went to one yeah I
just want to jump in because because at
the beginning of this um conversation we
said that the last time we saw each
other was a neft party right well I
didn't really give any context to that
so this is this is the context so Jeff
uh the the man I guess backing hourglass
yes you know he has all these different
companies and one of them is neft vodka
the Vodka brand and so you guys through
this 1920s party in Miami
um
at the Eden Rock Hotel yeah it was it
was very classy um Gideon couldn't get
in because he wasn't wearing a dinner
jacket so he had to we had to go get him
a dinner jacket
I literally threw mine to him and then
he crossed the Rope then he gave it back
to me yeah that was a loophole yeah yeah
so that's the level of like class and
sophistication with the event that we
went to
um so yeah I just wanted to get some
contact so we met at one of Jeff's
um you know fantasy 1920s party yeah
yeah it was really cool and I I was
worried because I when I saw that one of
the shows was very racy with the girl on
the cup and she started undressing and
knowing your tweets I was wondering are
you gonna like close your eyes are you
gonna look away or like
no I'm gonna close my eyes you should
close your eyes you're the man
I'm fine with them
yeah it was yeah it was quite racy
actually yeah yeah there's a woman
should be like full-on yeah I don't mean
I don't mind I mean I'm just not gonna
do that myself I understand you know but
like if you know a woman wants to do
yeah catering to their particular
audience so yeah I thought it was good
they throw events like that all over the
world when's the next one it was fun
there's been like five of them since
then but yeah but they're all over the
place I mean obviously we'll tell you
about the ones that are in your your
area yeah yeah yeah but uh basically I
mean the the story is that when they
purchased uh Nev vodka
um it was only in two countries it was
you know barely out there they've
expanded it a lot in terms of the
valuation it's like 100x worth more now
based on funding rounds when from when
they acquired it just four and a half
years ago now they're in 22 countries
and but to get it to that next level
where you're in a household name like a
Gray Goose or a Belvedere you have to do
a lot so that's why I mean they're
throwing events all over the world and
alcohol is a very tricky business
because every jurisdiction is different
with very very specific laws it's not
like just like Distributing t-shirts or
something because it's alcohol yeah yeah
yeah and so it's it's a big big project
but the cool thing is that as they are
growing and they're doing all these
events all these parties and everything
we get a chance at hourglass to kind of
just tag along and and make our um our
crypto project part of it which is
really really fun and I do have a little
bit of scoop for you okay there's going
to be a TV show about neft events and uh
we'll try to get you guys in like Gideon
should be like guest stars yeah yeah
yeah so that would be amazing so that's
in pre-production right now something
that I I did want to ask you and I don't
know if you're able to tell me this I
don't know
um so obviously there's the whale
episode and I really like the episode by
the way um because it was really nice to
sort of have like a second opinion from
another load of Judges who will
obviously Wales
um but like two two questions I have
first question is like where did they
come from like how did you how did you
decide which whales to pick because
there's one guy and I hope he doesn't
get offended by this which he sees this
but I was like what is he doing here he
doesn't know much about crypto and it
felt like he didn't really know what was
going on and then my second question is
did they actually invest in the projects
because I know some said they wouldn't
but there were some whales that agreed
to invest so did they well to be honest
with you I don't know if I can answer
that I I didn't follow up with them okay
so I don't I don't know like I didn't
say hey what what happened here right so
I I guess the the main answer is I don't
know I I think were you referring to Tom
dwan the poker player yeah he is really
into crypto believe it or not he is
really into crypto he kept like asking
me things and I'm like I'm like what
like I feel like a new crypto Tom what's
up he is a character he won the largest
live poker pot in history so you know
he's a he's a celebrity he's interesting
nice uh he is a character
um in terms of his crypto knowledge I
guess yes I mean we hung out after we
went to dinner after so you would know
more than I do because you know talking
with the vetting him I didn't vet him
that much in terms of his Kryptonite he
said he was going to send me 5K and some
[__] coin and he never did so he said
yeah
yeah gotcha gotcha gotcha yeah so um I
don't know Tom that well uh I think that
um Brian knows him better but Oliver one
of the the whales uh he chose not to
invest in either of them so there's
nothing to follow up with him they're
like we'll see this is my question
though like I need I should ask Oliver
but like
was he coming to the show open-minded
and like wanting to invest because I
felt like Oliver was just really just
like no don't invest in that no don't
like that you know I'll say this I I
worked when I worked in the uh mergers
and acquisition space and uh he's a you
know Oliver is a VC guy right and when
you're a fun guy the truth is that you
say no 99 of the time because when
you're holding all the money and all the
cards you have so much leverage you have
all the control you have unending deal
flow so I don't think that it was like
he came in meaning to say no or anything
uh I think it was just that you're used
to saying no unless you see something
that's like this is the one percent you
know uh this is the real unicorn yeah
and that's kind of your default yeah no
I know what you mean he was he is a
little bit grumpy yeah I was like
straight away he's like no that doesn't
sound good to me I was trying to do his
Northern accent it's just really nice
okay well I wouldn't do I would actually
ask Gideon to come on
my brother was there making sure nobody
um was was rude to me or inappropriate
with me or nobody was mean to me because
obviously like they're awoke and I'm not
you had the best advisor on set you were
the only one with like a personal
manager slash advisor on on set and and
Gideon
actually because um kid you only stayed
for like three out of what like the
seven filming days or something
um but you actually made quite an impact
as always when you weren't there
everyone's like where's Gideon gone yeah
yeah yeah yeah Justin I was like yeah Mr
brother's energy where is he yeah yeah I
said like whenever you're there
everybody everybody's always like oh God
he's too much energy but then when he
goes everybody fills the space
so how did you think it went what was
your opinion on um the whole uh
production
yeah no I thought it went very well I
thought it was oh did I just move the
whole table nearly sorry
no I thought it went really well I
thought the production was very
professional
um you know obviously we knew about the
people being woke and stuff like that
and I had said on previous podcasts you
can probably go back and watch this I
said look if anyone's gonna have a
problem with Leia okay I was like
screaming like just talk to me okay you
have a problem with her she says on
Twitter if she ever if you have a
problem with this that whatever it might
be like just talk to me so I was like
kind of Ready for War but then the funny
thing is when we got there it was all
very professional there was no problems
right you know I know you mentioned like
there was a few people who like don't
like layers opinions what she says on
Twitter about lizzo or like fat people
but no one said anything and everyone
was cool so I I just thought it was all
normal and you know like you were
complaining obviously saying oh my God
we're waiting around so much but like
jet said that's actually just how
production is like I used to do a lot of
production work as well and you're right
sometimes you can set the whole day up
just to seem like just to film like two
minutes a two minute scene it's just how
it is there's a lot of waiting around
but I thought it was really good I
thought it was professional it was
exciting and but yeah I was just ready
for the war aspect with the different
people I had warned you guys I had told
you guys before because I I kind of knew
just from guessing how you guys are and
then how you know the other people are
that this might happen so I I told you
guys in a group I just want you guys to
know that I know all about you guys
everything's gonna be good the people
who are funding the show have you know
know your opinions and we're good with
it like we're okay remember that well
it's funny because it makes you feel a
little bit a little bit better yeah and
you know it's funny because like we had
like Giggles like in between was like oh
my God a company that like we had a
little Giggles right right yeah yeah
yeah no we had like a lot of jokes in
between just about like the people and
stuff like that like it was all very
funny and like I was always I think also
what was funny as well the directors or
just some other people maybe they were
getting annoyed at me I don't know or
not but like I was always giving Leia
little tips and just different things to
say eyelash what's that remember the the
lashes you you you uh had a big
recommendation to take off the yes
exactly exactly stuff like that and like
I don't know if they got annoyed at me
but like because I'm a bit of a director
myself
um you know with everything that yeah
with yeah and like other talent and
stuff like that and I wanted to tell
Leia to do certain things and I kept
saying and maybe they were like oh this
is not in the direction we want it or
you know but I think also Justin the
director he kind of appreciated some of
the things he loves you he's coming to
see me okay right in he loves you guys
so yeah he can't wait to work work with
you guys again yeah yeah yeah like
Justin said he was like yeah I like what
you did there like yeah you told her
that or oh yeah that was good making her
do it more in this way and like maybe
even like just adjusting wardrobe on her
like making sure everything was fine so
because I think also like again because
this is 2023 and this new world where
everybody's like afraid to open their
mouth I think perhaps I think perhaps
sometimes like people might be afraid to
say to me oh Leia like pull your top up
or layer like do it more like this or
move your hair like they might be afraid
to say that to me so like Gideon can
jump in and just be like Leia pull your
top up like it's not an issue I mean
honestly I was there when you were I
mean everything that you told her always
made sense to me yeah yeah so because it
is a reality show too it's not like it's
scripted so then the director wants it
to be in one particular way and and
you're stepping on him because it's it's
her how she is so you know how she is
because you're with her all the time and
what's what you want to come out so it
it it you know I always thought it was
cool yeah that's what I was afraid of I
didn't want to step on the director's
toes you know and like I was and and
then you know and then after like
well no no no because it's annoying I
know how it is like if this if the
director's there and he's employed as a
director that's his job and then there's
this other guy who's kind of like
interfering with it that's very
irritating for that and I didn't want to
do that but I know you very well and I
also know directions and like so I was
like okay let me just give my little
input but obviously I didn't say
anything to the other judges right I
wouldn't guess it was just like for Leia
yeah
personal exactly yeah and actually you
know which I always will be you know
what that's actually what they do in
most reality series like you know like
you know like in selling sunset or like
the the big big reality shows that are
like several million dollars per episode
each character has a personal producer
and that's what you were that's why I
was yeah
the other ones were jealous actually not
I think George said to me like hey you
know like Leia has Gideon and then you
don't have somebody who's like just on
me yeah I know right because it makes
them feel more important actually you
know you had like an extra extra that's
so funny because it makes them feel more
important right like he's got his own
like independent producer yeah and then
even like when she was getting her
makeup done because like I'm quite I
always tell Leia you know like I don't
want her looking like completely caked
in makeup there's just nothing worse
than when a woman is just completely
caked like you said the eyelashes are
massive you know whatever it might be on
lipstick or even giant Hoops earrings so
I was always very on it with with the
makeup girls just saying like Okay just
you know a bit less bit less and like
again I don't know if they like that
before we came to set you know obviously
the the hair and makeup came to Leia's
hotel room and I was even telling this
woman like you know maybe a bit less
here and Leia was kind of looking at me
saying is it okay is it okay and I was
like maybe a bit less and she's probably
looking at me like you're not even a
[__] maker make a woman like what do
you know
you know but it's just like kind of like
my own intuition and what I think you
know suits me I think I remember at the
Morton's dinner I think Leia even liked
the lashes yeah right but you made the
call no less yeah oh yeah yeah yeah I
was just like they gotta go yeah those
lashes had to go no they literally put
like snico as a guest we've had on here
and he does it really well he calls it
there like these giant [__] butterfly
things it just looks so tacky
unattractive and it's just not for Leia
so I was like you know what when this
comes out we we're gonna look back on
this and think like this is gonna look
tackier and obviously there's nothing
you can do right yeah so I was like
let's just nip it in the bud now and get
rid of them get rid of the lashes no
it's true because like there's so many
occasions where like you know you you
think something is good in the moment
and then yes you do look back and you go
I shouldn't have done that and yeah
Gideon's rice is easier
what I would take away from all this
stuff I'm eating you guys knowing you
guys you guys just make a great team in
general and it's great because you're
yeah your brother some brothers and
sisters hate each other you know what I
mean and you guys like work together
obviously you bicker a lot which I think
would make its own great reality TV show
like like hanging out with the halperns
or something
um but uh you you've kind of are have
delegated areas where you both uh are
are kind of experts at and then you play
the strengths just right so it's it's
it's it's very powerful it knows us yeah
knows the secret I know the helper and
Mom yeah that's right well Gideon gets
really sick and tired of me so I'm glad
that you that you said that we're a good
team because now I don't think see how
bady's boy I see how good we are Gideon
how good we are yeah
there you go all right well thanks again
thank you all right anything else you
want to add thanks Jack good good chat
man cheers um so okay we have had season
one and you know you said it was quite
it's more like a pilot
um I'm curious what what's coming next
what does season two look like um and
when would you potentially start filming
yeah absolutely so what we're gonna do
is we're gonna look at season one we're
gonna look at how the distribution goes
we're gonna see which platforms we like
the best what and uh we're also going to
look at the reaction from the audience
uh see which parts of the show they they
like the best and uh we're gonna try to
do everything bigger and better I think
that by the time this airs we may have
already been begun uh taking submissions
for season two so that should be
exciting and I think there's gonna be a
lot and I think that one thing that uh
everybody
um requested was that more teams to
begin with yeah you know and uh also I
think one of the feedback uh the
feedback that um all three judges gave
is the that you want to you want it to
kind of go into a a mode where you get
to question them really hard right off
the bat as opposed to we kind of worked
our way
um yeah yeah I think that we're going to
make some adjustments next time so you
mentioned that hourglass is backed by
Jeff Mahoney who's a billionaire which
is obviously fantastic and amazing
um so what else is going on in The
Hourglass ecosystem that Jeff's involved
in yeah
um well I think people know us most from
the show just because it's such a fun
high profile project so that was the
first project that we incubated and we
have so many more in the pipeline uh one
of the projects is called Alpha district
and it's a web 3 game inverse where our
token The Hourglass weight token will be
the exclusive in-game utility token and
what makes Alpha District really
interesting is that it's not it's
created by some of the folks that worked
on some of the best non-blockchain games
so folks that worked on like Assassin's
Creed Clash of Clans Detroit becomes
human Star Wars Eclipse literally the
lead people on those on those projects
are working on Alpha districts so we're
really really excited Brian is heavily
involved in that
um and uh so that's going to be an
ongoing development and and another one
that is really really cool is called
Cosmos and this is a self-publishing app
it's kind of like a web 3 version of
Wattpad which sold a couple years ago
for 600 million dollars Wattpad connect
it it connects folks that are fiction
writers with readers but you can
self-publish without a filter but
there's all this web 3 integration and
we have it's it's going to launch with
um with weight token utility and we have
a lot of Partners already lined up that
are really good that want to use the
platform Neo Tokyo this thing of ours uh
Neo Masterpiece films uh just an example
and those are just two that we've
announced on our hourglass website we
kind of have this fun thing where we
give all of the projects that we
incubate a code name until we announce
what they actually are so there's all
these other code name projects project
Kronos is going to come out within a
couple days and I believe that it's
going to come out with uh over 1 million
already raised probably 1.5 million and
we have several more I'll give a little
bit of spoiler some of them are nift
apps where we integrate our token into
and in addition we want to make season
two of the next crypto gem much bigger
and better we're going to add some fun
weight token integration into season two
where fans can have gems where they're
participation gems and have some say as
to kind of suggesting projects to be on
the show suggesting influencers to guest
star on the show and so that'll be
really fun and we're also looking at
some other really interesting media and
TV Productions so that's why I want to
talk to you in Gideon after we film this
about you know some really really really
cool things one project in particular
where we're talking to a very successful
Hollywood producer who's worked with
some big big projects and celebrities
and
we're looking at something on the scale
of 40 times the budget of the first
season of next crypto gem so if people
think that we're just all first season
next crypto Jam All or nothing no no
that's just the very very beginning our
first proof of concept and everything is
just going to be bigger and better from
here wow you're doing so much this is
like so are you guys though don't forget
the Metro Bus this is like the Jeff bus
right that's what you guys call us oh
yeah yeah we like to call everything
that Jeff touches the you know because
he's our billionaire dude the Jeff verse
and so it's fun too and then you know
Brian one of our senior advisors uh we
love him we love you guys our Media
Partners as well yeah and uh he's always
introducing projects to us as well so we
sometimes we say the Brian verse and the
and the Jeff verse connecting them and
now we I think we need to create the
helper and verse how they all come
together we'll have to draw some diagram
with how they all intersect and
everything that's amazing that's pretty
cool yeah no I thought Jeff was like a
really interesting character when I met
um he's extremely tall
I always say for like I feel like um
some people are just like born for
certain jobs and positions and I can't
explain it he just looked like if anyone
hasn't seen what Jeff looks like just
imagine what a billionaire looks like
like right yeah yeah he fits the role
like he's like yeah he was super tall he
was dressed you know Dapper and he you
know yeah he stood up extremely straight
you know it was funny but um no he's a
really interesting guy and
um you know he spoke to me about all the
different
um projects that there that um he's uh
invested in and working on and obviously
the the dating app was that was one that
um we spoke about um he talked about his
previous blockchain project the only
thing we didn't quite align on was our
opinion on bitcoin which was quite funny
right um I know I know you have some
differences yeah I know that he doesn't
think you know Bitcoin is
um is like the next best thing
um well you have to keep in mind you
have to keep in mind he started a
company saved daily that has 7 000
institutional clients so in his mind
it's not that he doesn't like Bitcoin he
just doesn't think it's reached a point
of critical mass of institutional
adoption because when you think about it
yeah it hasn't been there but it has the
potential so he's I think it's it's not
that he completely disagrees with you
it's just that he he thinks of himself
as like hey I created save daily we got
7 000 institutional clients how many
institutional clients is like
institutions are using Bitcoin and so
he's not at the point where he he
reveres it you know but he he does see
the the potential and he loves our space
I mean look when you're that successful
you're kind of like in a in a video game
like living through the reality in the
world that we live in in god mode right
but this is kind of an embarrassing
thing to say because I work out of their
LA office but he's there before me every
day and often leaves before me he's so
dedicated he's someone who just really
loves helping people around him yeah and
he likes our space he likes what we're
doing so I mean he's already made it you
know beyond what anyone could do with
that type of success and wealth and uh
he he cares about the people around him
and so we're really really thrilled to
have him as our chairman of hourglass
Collective so grateful because you know
with that type of backing there's really
nothing that we can't do and we're love
having you guys involved with us on on
the journey that's amazing
um well I'm so excited to see the show
when it finally comes out obviously when
we at this this podcast it'll it would
have been already yeah so but you know
obviously yeah I'm really excited um and
I want to thank you so much for coming
on the show it's been so nice just to
sort of like reminisce and go back and
also you know hear more about what's
going on and with hourglass and
obviously with Jeff and neft and
everything so thank you so much for
coming on thanks so much for having me
it was a great time well Jack I want to
thank you so much for coming on it's
been such a pleasure I'm so excited to
see the show obviously
um by the time this podcast as the show
will be out um but I'm super excited to
see it um but how can people stay up to
date and you know find out different um
places to watch the show
um find out about the next season how
can everyone stay up to date with
everything that you guys are doing
absolutely the best way is to follow the
socials of the incubator behind it The
Hourglass Collective so you can go to
our website
hourglassx.com our hourglass Twitter at
hoursglass underscore wait and we have
all the information there the very very
latest we usually post several times a
day we also have links to our Telegram
and Discord and it's a fun fun story a
fun ride we have an amazing amazing
community and it's going to be
incredible going forward this is just
the very very beginning we're just gonna
do bigger and better things here amazing
I'm so excited thank you so much for
coming on chat thanks guys if you
enjoyed this episode please don't forget
to hit the like button and subscribe and
also let me know in the comments below
if you enjoyed the next crypto gem TV
show let me know what you'd maybe want
to see uh for season two and also don't
forget to hit the like button and
subscribe because we have a lot more
podcasts and a lot more incredible
guests coming